هنا ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب بشرايير وهذه
اخبار الساعه
لجنه الخارجيه بشيوخ الفرنسي تدعوا عبر
العربيه لتبني موقف صارم تجاه سلوك ايران
رساله المانيه من جبهه خاركب الاوكرانيه
الى روسيا وكيف تدعو برلين للاسراع بارسال
الدبابات
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر من الترقب مذكراته الامير هاري
يعني العائله المالكه متاحه بالاسواق
وتحقق الاسرع مبيعا في بريطانيا على
الاطلاق
من تباته النمو الى مخاوف الركود البنك
الدولي يفطر وتوقعات متشائمه لعام 2023
بسبب التضخم الفائده والحرب
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
سلطات الايرانيه تواصل تجاهلها اصوات
الاحتجاجات والتمديدات وتستمر في التضييق
على المتظاهرين اخر القرارات القمعيه هو
التشديد في المخالفات المرتبطه بقانون
الحجاب الالزمي والتي كانت الاساس في
اطلاق شراره هذه الاحتجاجات خطاب السلطات
القضائيه كان شديد اللهجه حيث امر المدعي
العام الايراني قوه حفظ النظام بتوقيف كل
ما يخالف قوانين الحجاب الالزاميه
والتطبيقي عواقب صارمه ومن شان هذا القرار
تاجيل الشارع الايراني بشكل اكبر سيما وان
رفض القواعد الصارمه لللباس كانت من اهم
النقاط التي تمركزت حولها الاحتجاجات
والمظاهره وفي خطوه اضافيه كذلك لتضييق
الخناقه مجددا على النساء خلال الفتره
المقبله قامت سلطات الايرانيه باغلاق عدد
من المقاهي والمطاعم على خلفيه عدم التزام
روادها بوضع الحجاب كما استانف تحذير
مالكيه السيارات من عدم التزام السيدات
على متنها بقواعد اللباس
ويبدو ان مطرقه القضاء تحولت الى اداه في
يد السلطه الايرانيه لتصفيه حساباتها وذلك
في ظل احكام الاعدام المتتاليه فضلا عن
محاكمه شخصيه معروفه كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لفائزه رقصا جاني ابنه الرئيس الايراني
الاسبق اكبر هاشمي راسان شامي والتي حكم
عليها بالسجن لخمس سنوات بسبب التحريض على
اعمال الشغب محاميه ابنه الرئيس الايرانيه
الاسبق اكدت ان موكلتها ستطعن في الحكم
وستلجا لمحكمه التمييز وتعد ابنه رخصا
جاني واحده من بين العديد من الشخصيات
الكبرى التي تؤيد الاحتجاجات وتنتقد القمع
الممارسه على المتظاهرين فمن هي ابرز
الشخصيات الاخرى التي تحمل امال
الايرانيين في الداخل والخارج
[موسيقى]
قال عضو مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي جلباب روجين
العربيه ان الموقف الفرنسيه الصارم تجاه
ايران بحق المحتاجين
ولا يتغير ولا بد ان يغادر النظام السلطه
الايراني نحن في مجلس الشيوخ نتبنى موقفا
صارما كذلك الحكومه الفرنسيه جددت موقفها
الصارم وانا انتمي للمعارضه ونتبنى هذا
الموقف يجب تبني موقف صارم حيل هذا النظام
الديكتاتوري الذي يجب ان يغادر سلطه
كما دعت شخصيات اوروبيه الى دعم المعارضه
ايران تشهد حركه شعبيه يشارك فيها كل
الشعب الالاف ينزلون الى الشوارع من مختلف
الاعمار تحت شعار الشعب يريد تغيير النظام
واسقاطه ويتطلع الى الديمقراطيه هذا تطور
جديد وغير مسبوق منذ سنوات وحدات المقاومه
التابعه للمجلس الوطني للمقاومه الايرانيه
تنظم وتشجع الاحتجاجات والنظام يعترف بان
المقاومه التابعه للمجاهدين خلق والمجلس
الوطني للمقاومه الايرانيه يحركون هذه
الاحتجاجات
الليله الدكتور سنه
القضائيه في المجلس الوطني للمعارضه
الايرانيه اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه
من العربيه
الداخل وعن بعض الشخصيات المعارضه لكن
انتم كمعارضه انتم تتبعون لمجاهدي خلق
انتم المعارضه الايرانيه ما هو دوركم ما
الذي تقومون به لدعم هذه الاحتجاجات في
الداخل
الى جميع مشاهدي قناه العربيه اعتقد ان
هذه اولا هذه الثوره لانها جاءت لتغير
موازينها لقوه بعيدا في الثقافه الموجوده
في ايران كما يراها العالم ايضا ان هناك
تغيير فعلا في مختلف مناحي الحياه همم لكن
بالنسبه لدور المجاهدي خال انتم تعرفون ان
هذه الثوره لم تاتي عن فراق هناك بابوت
هناك همم اربعه عهود من النضال المستمر من
قبل حركه مجاهد يخاف من انصارها داخل
ايران هناك بقوه اكثر من 100,000
شهيدته على درب الحريه في بلدنا منذ عام
1981 يعني انتم تنظرون الى هذه الاحتجاجات
على انها يعني همم نتاج طوال هذا النضال
الطويل طوال هذه العقود ترون انه هذا
وصلتم الان يعني هذه الاحتجاجات هي التي
يمكن ان تغير النظام دكتور
نعم انا انا اعتقد ان هذه
الاتجاهات كما تسمعون عنكم نحن نسميها
الثوره هذه الصوره هي استمراريه حركه
المغامره الايرانيه التي بدات منذ اربعه
وجود وكانت مستمره خلال هذه الصنابات
الطوال
وانتم تعرفون ان لا نقول
بلوغ هذه الحركه المستمره خلال هذه
السنوات همم وصلت الى درتها فيها
انتم تصرون على تسميتها بالثوره الايرانيه
الان وليست مجرد احتجاجات طيب هل انتم همم
في حركه مجاهدي خلق هل تشكلون انتم البديل
في حال سقط النظام الايراني انتم جاهزون
لكي تتولوا السلطه في ايران نعم همم
نقطه مهمه لان هناك تعرفون سنوات بدات
المغامره التي اشارت اشاره اليها الدكتور
ان هذه العادات بدات نشاطاتها
ونرى ان هذه العبادات هي التي كانت حقيقه
محرك هذه الانتفاضه وهذه الثوره هذا
الثوره كما ان هذه الوحدات هي اليه
استمراريه هذه الحركه التي تراها انها
استمرت فعلا لمده ما يغاربه 4 اشهر وست
ستستمر ان شاء الله خلال حتى طيب ثبوت هذا
النظام بالنسبه للبديل انتم تعرفون ان
هناك المجلس الوطني للمقاومه الايرانيه
التي تتالف من حركه مجاهده الحركات الاخرى
ومن الشخصيات السياسيه من همم ممثلين من
مختلف اللحوميات الايرانيه
هل هذه القوه موحده هل انتم موحدون
موحده تماما لها برامج خطوط قريبه محدده
هناك نقاط للحكومه المؤقته هناك ايضا
رئيسه جمهوريه للفتره اللي انت غاليه التي
السيده مريم رجبي على ذلك نعم جاهز والمهم
المهم الان ليس البديل بل المهم هو اسقاط
هذا النظام
يعني هناك حاجه الى همم
النضال استمراريه النضال لاسقاط هذا
النظام بعد ذلك شكرا يكون هناك من خلال
هذه النضال من هذا النظام او هذه النظارات
ايضا ستخرج سيخرج البديل الحقيقي ايضا
لهذا النظام كما اشارته اليه شكرا جزيلا
لكم الدكتور اسامه برق زاهدي انتم مسؤول
لجنه القضائيه في المجلس الوطني للمعارضه
الايراني
[موسيقى]
اكد المتحدث باسم الاصول الامريكيه الخامس
في لقاء مع العربيه ان الاسلحه التي تم
ضبطها علمتني سفينه صيد في مياه الخليج
كانت قادمه من ايران وفي طريقها الى
الحوثيين في اليمن
كانت احدى سفننا تقوم بعمليه تفتيش
الروتينيه و خلال تلك المهمه اكتشفوا
انقارب الصيد كان في المياه الدوليه في
خارجه عمان يهرب الاسلحه وهو عمل غير
قانوني وقد تم شحنها من ايران وكانت في
طريقها الى اليمن
الدولي لاسيما قرار مجلس الامن الدولي 22
عناصرنا تصرف تجاه القارب بدعم سفينتين
اخرىين وصادروا الاسلحه
شيك
[موسيقى]
من ايران نذهب الى افغانستان حتى اكدت
مصادر العربيه ان حكومه طالبان في ولايه
بغداد اعطت اصحاب صالونات التجميل
النسائيه في الولايه الواقعه شمالي
افغانستان اعطتهم مهنه لمده 10 ايام يغلق
محلاتهم حيث ان منطقه بخل مريا عاصمه
بغلان يوجد بها حوالي 20 صالون تجميل
النسائي كما امرت حكومه طالبان في منطقه
مزار شريف بولايه بلغ منع الفتيات من
العمل في المحلات التجاريه
[موسيقى]
اذا مره نحو عام ونصف على سيطره حركه
طالبان على افغانستان مده لم تتوقف خلالها
الحركه عن مفاجاه المجتمع الدولي بقرارات
لاقت انتقادا واسعا سيما في حق المراه
التي سلبت الكثير من حقوقها الاساسيه
فماذا يحدث تحديدا داخل الحركه التي ابدت
في البدايه استعدادا للتخلي عن بعض
قوانينها الصارمه بحثا عن اعتراف دولي لكن
شيئا من ذلك لم يحدث بهذا الخصوص عزل
صحيفه واشنطن بوست قرارات المنع الاخيره
في حق المراه الى سيطره المجموعه المتشدده
على حركه طالبان تقول الصحيفه وقالت ايضا
ان سلسله من القرارات التي اتخذتها طالبا
تتجاوز رغبات بعض مسؤولين الحركه بالعاصمه
[موسيقى]
السؤال المطروح الان من يتخذ القرارات
الحاسمه داخل الحركه تقول الصحيفه ان مركز
القرار داخل حركه طالبان ليس في كابل بل
تحول الى قندهار فالمرشد الاعلى لطالبان
هيبه الله اخو الزاد وزملائه من صقور
طالبان يتخذون القرارات الكبرى من قندهار
اين يقيمون ورغم تعيين وزراء في كابول الا
ان المرشد الاعلى تبقى له الكلمه الاخيره
في جميع القرارات هذا الكلام عزيزته
الصحيفه بتصريح لاحد المسؤولين في طالبان
يؤكد فيه ان اي قرار مهم لابد من الحصول
فيه على موافقه من قندهار منبها الى ان
العديد من الاحكام لا تحظى بموافقه
المسؤولينا في كابول
طالبان استبعاد المتواصل للنساء من الحياه
العامه
اكتوبر 2021 منع غالبيه الموظفات
الحكوميات من القدوم الى العمل
مارس 2022 منع فتيات من التعليم الثانوي
[موسيقى]
قرارات وطالبات كان لها ايضا الاثر
السلبيه على وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الشعب الافغاني وهو ما اشار اليه الامين
العام للمجلس النرويجي
للاجلاند حيث ادان حركه الطالبان انها
خدعه المنظمات الانسانيه عبر ماء النساء
من الاشتغال فيها ما يجعل استمرار نشاطها
مستحيلنا وابدا نفس المسؤول افضل مجلس
النرويجي للاجئين استئناف عمله من دون
نساء
[موسيقى]
اكدت قبل قليل القوات المواليه لروسيا في
دنياك السيطره الكامله على وسط بلده
سوليدار وكانت مصادر غربيه تحدثت عن
استعداد القوات الروسيه للهجوم على باقي
ما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القصبه الروسيه العنيف لم يحقق ايا نجاح
واوضحت الهيئه ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
عمليتها الاردنيه
عن صمود قوته امام هجمات جديده واكثر شده
على سوليدار اقرت المخابرات في البريطانيه
بان روسيا اصبحت تسيطر على اغلب المدينه
علما بان رسول الله
القوه الاوكرانيه وقالت ان موسكو شنت خلال
ساعه الاربع الماضيه 31 ضربه جويه و72
هجوما من منظومات الصواريخ
ونصلنا في دنياك اكد استمرار المعارك في
محيطي باخموت حيث تحاصر القوات الروسيه
المدينه
ما زال الجيش الروسي يحاصر او يطوق مدينه
باخمط من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه
وتطوق قوات فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه كما
هي قوات لوكانسكا الشعبيه بلده سلدار
المتاخمه لباخ موت من الناحيه الشماليه
وتدور هناك معارك ضاريه يعني معارك وحروب
في الشوارع قتال شوارع اذا صح التعبير بين
هذه القوات الخاصه والجيش الاوكراني الذي
ما زال صامدا ويحاول الجيش الروسي دفعه
للانسحاب من الناحيه الغربيه الاله
العسكريه الروسيه همم الثقيله تقصد
باستمرار المناطق الغربيه والطريق السريع
الذي يوصل امدادات عسكريه وبشريه الى
القوات المحاصره لذلك لا امدادات لهذه
القوات المحاصره بينما ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تقصف مناطق عديده منها نقطه اتصال
عبر سبوت منكسار لي حيث قطع الاتصال ما
بين القياده والمقاتلين على الجبهات
زهره وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا
بيربوك مدينه خاركيف في اوكرانيا حيث
التقت نظيرها الاوكرانيين متروكوليبا
لتكون بيربك اول مسؤوله غربيه تزوروا هذه
الجبهه في اوكرانيا وقالت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه اثناء تواجدها ان هذه المدينه
رمز للجنون المطلق لحرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الاوروبيه في اليد لمواجهه اي
تهديد الخارجيه من خلال توقيع اتفاقيه
التعاون والتنسيق اتفاقيه تحمل رسائل
مباشره الى موسكو عن عزم الطرفين مواصله
لدعم اوكرانيا في حربها امام روسيا في
تفاصيل الاتفاقيه خمسه محاور اساسيه اولها
ضروره خراط الحلف في الدفاع عن جميع
الخلفاء بالاضافه الى تعزيز الدفاعات
الاوروبيه ثانيا تولي الحلف مهام الحفاظ
على الامن عبر المحيط الاطلسي ثالث الجنود
اتفاق الجانبين على نقل الشراكه بينهما
الى مستويات الاعلى رابع هذا تعهد
الجانبين لعب دور المتكامل في دعم السلام
الدولي اوكرانيا
لقد وقعنا للتو لاعلان المشتركه الثالثه
لحلف الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي لتطوير
الشراكه بيننا منذ قرابه العام وساعات بعد
اجتياح روسيا لاوكرانيا في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير التقينا هنا في مقر
الناتو الرئيس بوتل اراد ان يسيطر على
اوكرانيا في ايام قليله واراد ان يقسمنا
ولقد فشل في الامرين معا وبشكل واضح القوه
الروسيه تم دحرها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه
وهو يرى الحريه والديمقراطيه كتهديد الله
وسيكون لهذا اثر
البعيد ولهذا يجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الروابط بين اعضاء ويجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الشراكه بين الميت والاتحاد الاوروبي ويجب
مزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا
مواصله دعم اوكرانيا في الحرب مع روسيا لم
يمر دون اثاره في حافظه موسكو حيث تعتبر
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي باتروشف
ان الصراع في اوكرانيا تحول لمواجهه بين
روسيا والنيتو مؤكدا ان الغربه يسعى الى
تقطيع اوصى لروسيا
وفي مواجهه التعاون المشاركه بين مختلف
الحلفاء الغربيين تتجه موسكو الى تطوير
اسلحتها سينما النوويه منها وهو ما اكدها
وزير الدفاع الروسي سرجو الذي قال ان
موسكو ستواصل تطوير الثالوث النووي كضامن
لسيادتها وسلامتها كما اعلن شيبوه ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه ستقوم بتطوير سنه
الاسلحه الهجوميه في المستقبل القريب
[موسيقى]
قاعده قاعده
النووي والحفاظ على استعداده القتالي لان
الدرع النووي كان ولا يزال الضامن الرئيسي
لسياده البلاد وسلامه اراضيها سنعمل ايضا
على زياده القدرات القتاليه للقوات الجويه
ومن بينها عمل المقاتلات والقاذفات في
المناطق التي تعمل فيها انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الحديثه وكذلك تحسين الطائرات بدون
طيار
فوق تاكليتات نكبر
نتابع من موسكو مع مراسلين عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا تقارير
للمخابرات البريطانيه تؤكد ان الروس
سيطروا على سوليدار قربا باخمود قبل قليل
كان هناك خبر يقول انه قوات مواليه لروسيا
اعلنت السيطره على سوليدار ولكن هل تم
الاعلان رسميا في موسكو اذا تمت السيطره
او ما هي حقيقه الوضع في سوليدار
وما زالت الصامته بما يخص قضيه
لكن كما تحدثت صهيب قوات ثانيه وصلوطاتها
تتحدث عن سيطره قوات فاجنر على وسط
المدينه وهذه القوات الان تقوم بعمليات
تمشيط لضواحيها والشوارع المجاوره بها
طبعا اعلان موسكو هذا اعلانه هذا ياتي بعد
ورود تقارير عسكريه مختلفه المصادر الى
يعني الى موسكو على منصات التواصل في
التلجرام وفي غيرها الصفحات عسكريه صهيب
تتحدث وتظهر مقاطع فيديو عن تواجد عناصر
الان في وسط مدينه سوليدر هذا الشيء طبعا
معارك وسلسله من المواجهات العنيفه خلال
الفتره الماضيه وخروج العديد من قواتيه
نحو المنطقه الغربيه
طيب بالسيطره على سوليدار هل اصبحت الطريق
سالكه باتجاه ضخمت بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن القول بان
الطريق اصبحت سالكه لكن الان تم احكام
يعني الافضل نوعا ما من الجهه الشرقيه ومن
الجهه الجنوبيه هي مناطق طبعا استراتيجيه
بشكل كبير للوصول طبعا
مدينه سوليدار يعني هي قرابه الثلاثين او
40 كيلو متر الحديث يدور عن ضواحي همم
المدينه والضواحيها لكن طبعا تبقى معركه
المعركه الاكبر صهيب وطريق نحوها قد يشهد
العديد من العمليات القتاليه خاصه
الاوكرانيه نحوها الغربيه التي من المتوقع
ان تبدا الاعمال القتاليه فيها بشكل مكثف
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو شكرا جزيلا
اشارت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه عن مشاركه
كبيره للمواطنين الفنلنديين في مواقع
الكترونيه تتيح كتابه رسائل وتوقيعات على
قذائف المدافع الاوكرانيه المستخدمه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وذلك مقابله
مبالغه ماليه تتراوح بين 200$ و500 دولار
امريكي وتذهب هذه الاموال دعما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مواجهه روسيا التي تضغط
بدورها بسلاح الطاقه على اوروبا وبشكل
كبير على فيندر
اصوات المدافع الاوكرانيه المدعومه من
فنلندا في حربها مع روسيا ليست كافيه
للفرنديين لابداع دعمهم في الصراع الدائري
وسائلهم على قاده في المدافع تسجل
استمراريه وتصميما لهذا الدعم منصه في
الانديه غير ربحيه تدعى صائمه
تعلن السماحه لدعم القوات الاوكرانيه
بالتوقيع وكتابه رسائل على ذخائر
الاوكرانيه ثم اعادت نشرها في ما بعد
التوقيع مقابل الدعم المالي ما بين 200
دولار امريكي الى 500 قيمه لوضع اسماء
ورسائل الفيلاليين على قداء في المدفعيه
[تصفيق]
ووفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه فان
المواقع الالكترونيه المشابهه والمتخصصه
بالتبرع لاوكرانيا جمعت مئات الالاف من
الدولارات منذ اطلاقها فيما تحظى فنلندا
من نصيب الاكبر من هذه التبرعات
قلق المواطنين الفنلنديين من ان تطال
بلادهم نيران الحرب الروسيه عكسته ارقام
اشارت اليها التايمز حيث دعى
58% من الفنلنديين الى رفع ميزانيه البلاد
العسكريه كما اعرب
85% عن قلقهم بشان تصعيد روسي المتزايد
تحرك فلنديين بالتبرع والتوقيع على القضاء
في الاوكرانيه يتزامن مع مواجهتهم ازمه
طاقه فبعد ما اعتمدت فنلندا على ثلث
احتياجاتها من روسيا الان تقترب من الرقم
صفر الامر الذي يجعل تفسيرا لمواجهه
فرنديين للساقيه برسائل القذائف
الاوكرانيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه العربيه في
مكتبه بايدينا السابق الذي عثر فيه على
وثائق البيت الابيض السريه القصه بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
مذكرات هذه المثيره للجدل باتت بين يدي
القارئ وكما صنع الحدث قبل طرحه واصله
كتاب
للامير هاري صناعه الحدث حتى بعد فرحيه في
الاسواق البريطانيه الكتاب سجل رقما
قياسيا خلال ساعات بعد عرضه في المكتبات
حيث بات الكتاب اسرع مبيعا في العالم ضمن
الكتب الواقعيه وذلك
وقالت الصحيفه ان الكتابه بعت منه حوالي
400,000 نسخه حتى الان وكان الكتاب قد خلق
ضجه واسعه قبل طرحه بعد تداول تسريبات
منها اشاره الى اتهامات للعائله الملكيه
فضلا عن اعترافات جريئه من الامير حول
علاقته بافراد عائلته
اخيرا كتاب سيره الامير هاري على رفوف
المكتبات والمتاجر صار في متناول محبي
الامير وكاريه على السواق لتصفح الصفحات
ال 416 وما تحتويه من فيضا من التفاصيل
المثيره عن حياته وعن الخلافه داخل عائلته
من كشفه عن مشاجره مع اخيه وصولا الى
اعترافه بقتل 25 مقاتلا في طالبان وكلامه
عن طاعه المخدرات كلها امور اثارت ردود
فعل عديده وستترك بلا شك اثرا على مبيعات
الكتاب وشعبيه الامير
اشتريت الكتاب لانني اريد ان اكون جزءا من
التاريخ ولمعرفتي ما جرى في القصر خصوصا
الامور التي لم نسمع عنها من قبل وكيف
تصرفت الصحافه مع هاري
لترويج كتابه وما زعم مثيره طالت افراد
العائله الملكيه صدمت متابع الامير
وعائلته من جهه ومؤيد العائله المالكه من
جهه اخرى وان كانت الغالبيه ترى ضروره
ابقاء اسرار العائله الملكيه ومشاكل
اعضائها حديثه القصر لن اقتني الكتاب
لاننا قضينا وقتا كافيا للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع وحصل على ما يكفي من الدعايه ولا
اظن ان من المنطقي شراء الكتاب
وليس لدي شيء ضد الكتاب اتعاطف مع الامير
لكن معه انه يستحق اضاعه وقتي لقراءته
سيجن الامير هاري الملايين الى جنيهاتي من
مبيعات الكتاب وسيخص جزءا منها لمنظمه
خيريه اسسها لمساعده الاطفال المصابين
بفيروس نقص المناعه في افريقيا
يحتل كتابه مذكرات الامير هاري المرتبه
الاولى في قوائم مبيعات الكتب على موقع
امازون ويتوقعوا ان يحضر الكتاب باقبال
كبير في المكتبات بعد حمله التسويقيه منذ
الاعلامي عن نشر سيرته الذاتيه
كعادتها التزمت العائله الملكيه السمطه
ولم تعلق على مزاعم الكتاب تركه الكلام
لهاري وللقراء اللي يحكموا على تداعيات
اصداره على المدى الطويل مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن
والعربيه تجولت في لندن واستطلت بعض
البريطانيين عن رايهم في مذكرات الامنيه
البريطانيين المعتدين على العائله الملكه
يدركون انه من وقت الى اخر يدخل احد بينهم
لا يستحق مكانته لكن هذا لا يعني ان اعضاء
العائله الاخرين غير جديرين بالاحترام يجب
ان نتجاهل هاري
الكتاب ولا اعتقد انه من الامور التي نريد
ان نكتب او نتحدث عنها
وصل الى هذه المرحله هذا سيئون له
فعلا ذلك للعائله الملكيه امرا سيء يجب ان
يبقى ذلك امرا خاصا وخلف الابواب المغلقه
اعتقد انه سيؤدي الى مزيد من الدعم
للعائله الملكيه لكن هاري سيخسر ذلك
الدعامه الناس تنظر اليه على انه طعنهم في
الظهر
اعتقد ان الكتابه فيثير ضجه رغم اننا
اطلعنا على افضل ما فيه من خلال تسريبات
الصحافه وما قاله هاري مؤخرا للتمهيد
للكتاب لا اعتقد شخصيا انني ساجد شيئا
جديدا فيه لكنني متاكده انك اذا كنت مؤيدا
للعائله او نهار ستجد ضالتك فيه
في احدى القنوات البريطانيه قام المذيع
الشهير فيسبوك برمي الكتاب الذي نشره
الامير هاري في سله المهملات مباشره على
الهواء قائلا من الكتابه غير مناسب شهيده
سبايدر مان
احمد ياسين عضو حزب المحافظين البريطاني
مرحبا بكم معنا سيد احمد هل
توافقن عندما القى كتاب هاري سبير او
الاحتياطي رماه في سله المهملات
نعم بالتاكيد انا ارى هذا هو مكان مثل هذا
الكتاب لان يعني تصرفات الامير هاري هي
بالتاكيد مؤذيه جدا
للعائله الملكيه ولما كانت بريطانيا في
العالم خاصه بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بريطانيا تحاول ان ترسم صوره
جديده عالميه بالنسبه اليها خاصه في
مجموعه دول الكومنولث
ال 54 همم بلدا هناك 15 بلدا من مجموعه
ترفع التاج الملكي البريطاني وبالتاكيد
مثل هذه البلبله التي احدثها الامير هاري
سوف تؤثر في امكانيه هذه الدول في رفع
التاج الملكي البريطاني وقد بدات يعني مثل
هذه المحاولات في التخلي عن التاج خاصه من
قبل همم
في ال- في الحقيقه وراي العابدين الحقيقه
ولكن ثمه على الاقل 400,000 شخص اشتروا
مذكرات الامير هاري حتى الان بمعنى ان
هناك اقبال منقطع النظير على قراءه تفاصيل
الخلاف وما حصل للامير وطبيعه الخلاف بينه
وبين اسرته الا يعد هذا ايضا مقياسا لمدى
اهميه هذه المذكرات كذلك والمعلومات
الوارده فيها عن طبيعه العلاقات في
العائله الملكيه
يعني بالتاكيد اصدار مثل هذا الكتاب سوف
يحدث يعني حب الاطلاع ورغبه الاطلاع عند
شريحه واسعه جدا من البريطانيين وكذلك
ايضا خارج بريطانيا انطلاقا من الاهميه
الكبيره التي تمثلها العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه وتقاليدها العريقه بالتاكيد
مثل هذا الكتاب سوف يحدث مثل هذه الرغبه
ولكن انا متاكد بعد كل من يقرا هذا الكتاب
سوف ينقلب في رايه وفي تقييمه ضد شخص
الامير هاري
استطلاعات الراي من يوغف لان يعني هذا
الكتاب وما قام به الامير هاري يعكس شخصيه
مهتزه يعني عندما عندما يذكر بانه قتل 25
عنصر من حركه الطالبان يعني ما المغزى ما
الهدف من مثل هذا من مثل هذا الكلام حاليا
يعني تكلفه تاميمه سوف تتضاعف بالتاكيد هو
حاليا مهدد من قبل الجماعات الاسلاميه
بسبب هذا بسبب هذا ال- ال- التزكير كذلك
ايضا نقطه اخرى ذكرها في كتابه عندما
عندما لبس بدله وعليها شعار انزيه يعني هو
قالها بوضوح انها انه قام بفعل ذلك تحت
تاثير اخيه وزوجته يعني هذا يعكس انه همم
انه صاحب شخصيه مهتزه غير متزنه وما قام
به بالتاكيد اذى نفسه قبل ازاله العائله
الملكه نعم الجميع الان يترقب رده فعل
العائله همم المالكه سيد احمد همم
والعائله وبريطانيا طبعا هناك مناسبه مهمه
جدا في السادس من مايو القادم وهي همم
اعتلاء العرش من قبل الملك تشارلز الثالث
رسميه هل برايك سيتم حل الخلاف في ربما
خلال هذه الفتره هل سيكون ربما هناك
امكانيه للمصالحه ام لا الامير هاري الان
وزوجته
خارج العائله الى الابد
الخلاف اصبح كبير جدا وخاصه ان الكتاب
يوجه اذا ادت واضحه واتهامات سافره
للملكه يعني زوجه
الملكه كبيره جدا نعم كذلك ايضا الامير
هاري يعني لمحه بالعنصريه ضمن تصرفات
افراد العائله
وتراجع عن مثل هذا التوصيف همم قائلا بانه
كان يقصد بان هناك
ميول لا شعوري للتمييز بين افراد العائله
الملكه وهنا هنا يخص ابنه همم ارتي عندما
يعني همم يتهم العائله الملكه بمثل هذه
الاتهامات بالتاكيد الخلاف اصبح
يعني بعيد كل البعد عن حلول مباشره او
حلول حتى على المدى البعيد كذلك ايضا قاعه
الاساسيه التي تتحدث عنها صحف التابلويد
هنا في بريطانيا بان زوجته ميغان هي يعني
اتهمت بشكل مباشر بانها كانت تتصرف بشكل
سيء وبشكل عشوائي مع مع خدمه القصر
وبالرغم من ذلك هو هو غضا الطرف عن ذكر
مثل هذه التصرفات لذلك انا ارى بان الخلاف
كبير جدا بين الامير هاري وباقي افراد
العائله خاصه وان للامير للملك تشارج يعني
ان توصف زوجته بهذه الاوصاف يعتبر ذلك خط
احمر وقد تجاوز هذا الخط بوضوح امير هذه
لذلك الخلاف كبير جدا شكرا جزيلا لك احمد
ياسين عضو حزب المحافظين البريطاني
[موسيقى]
خطروا الركود يواصل التربص بالاقتصاد
العالمي والتحذيرات تتوالى بهذا الخصوص
اخرها تلك الصادره عن البنك الدولي الذي
انضم الى قائمه المؤسسات التي دقت ناقوس
الخطر بخصوص تهديد الركود على الاقتصاد
العالمي البنك الدولي قال ان الاقتصاد
العالميه سيقترب بشكل خطير من الركود خلال
العام الجاري مدفوعه بضعف النمو في جميع
الاقتصادات الكبرى بالعالم كما خفض البنك
الدولي توقعته لنمو الاقتصادي العالمي هذا
العام الى نحو 1.7 فقط مقارنه مع توقعاته
السابقه البالغه ثلاثه في المئه
وتنبؤات البنك الدولي هذه تنظر بازمه
اقتصاديه خلال العام الحالي فاذا ثبتت
الدقه هذه التوقعات سنكون امام الثالث
اضعف نمو اقتصادي سنوي في ثلاثه عقود بعد
الركود الشديد الذي نتج عن الازمه الماليه
العالميه لعام 2008 والركود الناجم عن
جائعه فايروس كورونا لعام 2020 الاكثر من
ذلك نبه البنك الدولي الى ان ضعف
الاستثمار سيؤدي الى تدهور قطعي التعليم
والصحه في الدول الفقيره وكان التوقعات
مماثله قد صدرت قبل اسبوعين من صندوق
النقد الدولي الذي اكد ان ثلث العالم سيقع
في ركود هذا العام
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه منظمه الصحه
العالميه تؤكد ان المتحولات المنتشره في
الصين
في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
في مركزه للدراسات تعود الى الفتره التي
تسلم فيها منصب نائب الرئيس قد تعرب بيضا
للمساءله بتشجيع من جمهوريين مجلس النواب
طبعا ونقل قناه سي ان ان هذه الوثائق
تتعلق بايران وباوكرانيا
في هذا المبنى في الطابق السادس عثر على
وثائق التقريبا 10 صنفت بانها وثائق سريه
تابعه للرئيس بيضين عندما كان يشغل منصب
نائبا رئيس طبعا هذا سبب احراج كبير للبيت
الابيض لانه اتهم بالزواجيه المعايير
بالمقارنه مما حدث مع الرئيس ترامب الذي
حقق الاف بي اي في الوثائق التي وجدت في
مره لارجو لكن البعض يقول بانه لا مقارنه
اولا البيت الابيض اعرب عن تعاونه مع طبعا
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي وقال بانه يريد ان
يعيد كل هذه الوثائق الى الارشيف الوطني
وان هذه الوثائق لا تحمل مثلا اسرار نوويه
او غيرها لكن بغض النظر رئيس مجلس النواب
كيف مقاسي قال بان الامر مقلق للغايه وهذا
طبعا سيسبب احراج كبير للبيت الابيض وقد
يؤثر على مستقبل الرئيس السياسي
هذا هو حصلت العربيه على صور خاصه من امام
مكتب الرئيس الامريكي جو بادن في مركزه
للدراسات حيث تم العثور على وثائق البيت
الابيض السري
[موسيقى]
ع مباشره من واشنطن مع مراسله ناديه اهلا
بك معنا اذا انت ما تزالين في نفس المكان
الذي يضم مكتب الدراسات التابع لجوبايدن
سؤال بشكل مباشره هل بايدن حقا في ورطه
اهلا بك صهيب قد يكون في ورطه لانه كما
تعرف هذه المدينه مسيته للرياض وخصوصا
الان بعد سيطره الجمهوريين على مجلس
النواب قبل قليل رئيس لجنه الاستخبارات
طلبه من ابرهانز وهي المسؤوله عن
الاستخبارات الوطنيه التحقيق في هذه
الوثائق هل هي بالفعل تشكل خطر على امن
الدوله ام لا اذا سيتم استخدام سياسييا هل
هو في ورطه كبيره ام لا هذا ما ستتكشف عنه
الايام القادمه لانه كما تعرف هناك حديث
على ان اذا كان رئيس يرشح نفسه بالولايه
ثانيه ام لا قد يؤثر عاد على الاتهامات
بالزواجيه المعايير وبغض النظر حتى حتى لو
كان لا مقارنه بينه وبين الرئيس ترامب
الذي احتوى منزله في ما لارجو على المئات
من الوثائق التي صرفت سوريا وغايه في
السريه الامر مختلف وطبعا كان هناك اقتحام
من قبل عناصر الاف بي اي لكن في جو سياسي
اكيد سي على الرئيس وسيكون هناك اسئله
كثيره من الصحفيين ومسائله من الجمهوريين
بالتحديد
الجمهوريون بداوا بتنقيص حياه بايدر منذ
وصولهم الى الاغلبيه في النواب شكرا جزيلا
لكي ناديه بلبيسي مباشره من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
كشف المحافظه هيئه الحكومه الرقميه احمد
سوايان ان من اولويات هيئه الحكومه
الرقميه دمج منصات وتحول من 36 منصه في
قطاع الحج الى منصه نصفك مشيرا الى ان
نصفك تقدم 121 خدمه تتنوعه بين قطاع
الاعمال والافراد لخدمه 30 مليون شخص وانه
جرى اصداره اكثر من 750,000 تاشيره عمره
لمعتمرين افراد خلال اقل من شهرين منذ
موسم العمره الحاليه
[موسيقى]
ان تشغل العالم مره اخرى بكرونا بعد عوده
حالات الاصابه الى الارتفاع
داخل البلاد اوروبا تترقب مره اخرى كيف
يمكن لهذه الموجه الجديده داخل الصين ان
تؤثر على مختلف البلدان داخل القاره بهذا
الخصوص اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه انها
لا تتوقع ان يؤثر الارتفاع في الاصابات في
الصين بشكل كبير على القارات العجوز
ان السبب وراء ذلك وان المتحورات المنتشره
في الصين موجوده اصلا في اوروبا وداعت
منظمه الدول الاوروبيه الى اتخاذ التدابير
متناسبه وغير تميزيه حيايا للمسافرين
الوافدين من الصين
[موسيقى]
رغم انتهاء موسم اعياد الميلاد الا ان
الوضع يختلف في قريه النرويجيه حيث تقاموا
مسابقه سانتا وتسمى تحديدا الالعاب
الشتويه
وتجمع المسابقه متبارين من جميع انحاء
العالم حيث يتنفسون في مسابقه مختلفه من
الانترنت
اه اه
نعم نعم
[موسيقى]
اللقاء